hello everyone and welcome back to our
mini alireza saga we are uh trying to
get alireza to 2800 and uh he has the
opportunity to do so uh in this game the
problem is his opponent is alexander
grishok and he's playing with the black
pieces now uh if you want to be 2800
that's something that um
you're going to have to do you know but
it's uh you know playing it at this
level at the this consistency is not an
easy feat out of the seven uh games that
alert has already played in this
tournament uh he won six and drew one
only only one draw against even
character so winning against grishok
here with the black pieces would be well
it would be worthy of uh
gaining a 2800
rating so without further ado let's
check it out uh and uh see what uh sasha
has to say about this so grishop with
the white pieces opens with e4
we have e5 val it has a knight f3 knight
to c6 and bishop to b5 going for the ruy
lopez with a6 more of his defense uh
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 and
for those of you who who maybe do not
know uh grisha is also a former member
of the 2800 club himself uh we have
castles and the b5 now challenging this
bishop here so it's a very very standard
line of the rue lopez the columbus
variation bishop to b3 and bishop to c5
preparing to castle king side
we have c3 preparing d4 and now d6 we
have d4 striking in the center and the
bishop back to b6 and now bishop to e3
so like i said we've had this many many
times
on the board we have castles and now
knight b to d2 and here
uh the the usual moves black plays here
are h6 uh and the bishop to g4 some
other moves are uh you know played a
little bit less but here uh alireza goes
for rook to b8 it's a very rare move uh
and it's uh well obviously aimed at uh
um sasha here so let's see how he deals
with this but it's not a new move uh we
have h3 stars says all right i'm gonna
take away the g4 square from your pieces
uh and now uh there are some games where
h6 was played but here we have brook to
e8 and it is now already as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game so uh
alireza throws uh uh garishuk out of
book and he wants to see how he will
deal with this new situation so rook to
e1
also another standard move uh we have
bishop to b7 now it is a bishop pair is
very nicely placed if the position opens
up uh the the duo could be very deadly
uh and now knight to g5 asking galireza
what are you gonna do with about this f7
pawn yes europe is very nice on e8 but
the f7 point is now weak and he's
probably checking if already wants to go
for d5 but the d5 is maybe just you know
trading everything uh
out of the opening basically if you play
d5 we can play captures on d5 and now we
can't capture the pawn if we captured
upon the problem is queen h5 and his
game over white wins so there's that so
after this captures on d5 you would have
to play knight to a5 now you have plenty
of pieces attacking that d5 pawn and now
we would just see uh something like the
captures on e5 knight capture some b3 a
nice capture fest here knight captures
uh for example rook captures on e5
bishop captures and b6 we're going to
play rook captures on e1 with jerk first
queen capture c captures on b6 and now
we're gonna play queen to e5 at a
defender
uh that is spawn and you can't really
capture it even though you're attacking
it three times because rook to d1 could
be uh you know a bit of a problem for
black so this is just you know trading
everything and you you really haven't
achieved all that much
uh i mean okay you do have a past deep
on but uh
you know
maybe you can do better so instead after
instead of this after knight to g5 we
have rook to e7 all it is that just
defense here and now comes d5 now sasha
grabs the d5 square we have bishop
captures on e3 and now rook captures an
e3 this is a must the movie if you go
for captures on c6 first then we're
going to capture on d2 and after queen
captures we're going to play bishop
captures on c6 and well you're just down
a pawn so we can't have that so after
bishop captures an e3 we have rook
captures on e3 and now knight to a7 now
you're going to shift the knight to c8
and then uh you can go to b6 and you
know that's that's how all it is it
wants to do it even though it seems more
natural to bring the knight on a5 at the
pressure the bishop then push push the c
pawn as we've seen uh uh you know in the
royal open as many times before but okay
uh now grisha goes for a6 puts pressure
on the b5 pawn and knight the c8 alireza
just continues uh
his plan with a captures on b5 a
captures on b5 and now c4 played like
like a computer uh just putting pressure
on black's position and basically
threatening to win a pawn with c
captures on b5 and the grisha did spend
a little bit more time than elireza here
he's down to 40 minutes and the clock
holiday has some one hour and five
minutes on the clock uh and well it's
move 18 so plenty of uh
moves uh left to reach time control and
basically you have to decide how do you
want to go about this do you want to
just capture on c4 which of course you
can always do yeah or do you want to
maybe throw in an h6 first dislodge the
knight from this active square and then
maybe play
some like b captures on c4 or you want
to defend your pawn with c6 so those are
options um you know they all have their
uh you know good sides and bad sides
none of them really has any bad sides
they're all good moves uh but alireza
goes for c6 so he puts pressure on the
d5 pawn and it defends the b5 pawn uh
grishok now captures on c6 we have
bishop captures on c6 and now c captures
on b5
and now this is well it's not maybe a
critical position but it's a very
interesting one because the the absolute
best move for black here is just bishop
back to e8 to add more defense to the f7
pawn because you can see that white
still has this annoying pressure on f7
so maybe including h6 at some point uh
did make sense but you know it's a it's
a very very complicated position but
alireza didn't go for this he just
captured here uh right away it's better
to just move the bishop and allow the
rook to capture uh but now agarishuk has
this very very annoying move bishop
captures on f7
uh and the the the thing is the queen is
now coming to b3 uh to add more pressure
on this diagonal and this is going to be
a problem for black as you'll see so
rook captures on f7 we have to play this
now comes queen to b3 now threatening to
pick up the rook so d5 blocking the
queen's diagonal and now we capture an
f7 attacking black's queen king captures
and now e captures on d5 so we're
threatening to uh well do all sorts of
nasty discoveries here uh but now queen
captures on the e5 uh offering a queen
trade uh and here grishok uh took the
queen he played queen captures on d5
although worth considering was queen to
c3 this is a a really a fine idea uh
threatening that queen to c7 check to
pick up the rook on b8 and you would
have to be very careful here basically
uh you have to part with the e5 point
you have to move the king and then for
example rook captures an e5 we attack
the queen put some more pressure along
the fifth rank and after let's say
something like queen to b7 we're gonna
play rook eight to e1 and white really
gains
a lot of momentum here yes
black still has two pieces for the rook
but uh
um it's four pawns against two so white
would
have some pressure here but okay sasha
decides against this he decides to trade
queens queen captures on the e5 with
check knight captures on d5 attacking
the rook and now rook captures an e5 we
have knight back to f6 and now knight to
e4 offering another trade of knights
so alireza declines this he plays knight
to d7 attacks the rook rook to d5 and
now bishop to c6 putting pressure on the
rook also the knight has to be defended
but now we play rook to d2 uh the the
knight is defended by not defending the
knight if uh uh elireza captures here
we're going to capture this knight so
here knight to e5 getting rid of this
threat and uh here rook to e1
again maybe worth considering was knight
to g5 it's a really tricky move because
the h7 pawn is also attacked and you
can't really go king to g8 because rook
to d8 will be checkmate after the bishop
blocks so this is just checkmate so we
can't play that we're to have to go to
g6 to defend our pawn and now we can
play this very nice f4 move defend our
knight attack the black knight and after
the knight moves somewhere let's say
here we attack the rook and
there's a double attack on the b two
pawn now we play rook d4 attack the the
knight here and after we move the knight
uh
you have to you know bring the knight
back to help out with the defense for
example here we play rook to a6 and now
this could be an issue for black it's a
very nice attack for white so maybe
maybe something
along these lines would would have been
good for white and now you don't really
have a good way of dealing with this you
have to play some like h6 let's say rook
captures on c6 h captures on g5 now
we're going to have f captures and g5
rook captures on b2 and now for example
rook to d5 and white is white has all
the pressure in the world here black
can't really do anything with the
knights it would be very hard to play
this uh but okay after knight e5 grisham
went to rook to e1
and now we have uh bishop captures on e4
so he wants to
minimize the the number of pieces on the
board rook captures on e4 and now not
rook to b5 to defend the knight although
this does activate the the pieces a
little bit more but again going back
knight to c6 and here the situation on
the clock is 11 minutes for grishok and
uh
some 20 something 21 minutes for alireza
so rook to d3 uh trying to trick uh
alireza for uh
going after the b2 pawn of course if if
this is captured then uh it's just game
over rook f3 check you can see that the
rooks are controlling both the endf file
and now
if you go back then it's just checkmate
rook to e8 checkmate so you're going to
have to go to g6 but still rook to a6
check and the the knight here is lost so
of course the pawn cannot be captured we
have knight eight to e7 and now b3 so
now the pawn on b3 is nicely protected
and it's a pass pawn so it's two knights
against the rook but the knights are
very awkwardly placed they are you know
getting in each other's way and that's
not the way you want to use the knights
usually knights are best used if they're
not defending each other so here we have
king back to g8 and interestingly here
uh grishok is already below three
minutes so where alireza has some 17
minutes on the clock he plays g3
here already below two minutes again you
could go for some rook to e6 action but
it doesn't really do all that much for
example king f7 you can play this but
it's basically a draw offering we're
gonna capture on b3 and now you can win
the two nights but still you're up upon
this is a a dead draw so instead after
g3 we have knight to f5 here and now
king to g2 we have knight f to d4 and
now alireza basically offers the draw
again he offers the the two knights for
the pawn uh and there doesn't seem to be
uh anything all that uh much better
because now if you don't capture the
knight the the knight is just uh in in
the center of the board uh it's a very
strong piece even though the knights are
still defending each other you can have
to capture it this is uh there's really
no other way for you to make progress
with white so here he goes for it rook
captures on d4 we have knight capture
sunday for rook captures and rook
captures on b3 and we have this end game
that's basically a a dead draw
uh and rook to d7 that's okay now the
the white rook is very active alireza's
king can't approach deeper into the
position uh but um
uh he still continues playing of course
he's not just going to draw this he's up
a pawn but also this is a team event
and uh board four is losing for for team
russia uh maxime lagarde is uh beating
uh uh andre sipenko and of course uh
gurishuk has to try to uh make something
out of this position so here we have h5
vial there is a rook to d5 and now uh
just the g6 we have rook to d7 and now
king to f8 so not much to be done here
of course this is a complete draw uh g4
we have captures captures rook to e3 now
comes f3 we're going to try and make
some uh progress with our king rook to
b4 uh king to h4 and now rook to b5 so
not allowing the king deeper into the
position if you allow this then it could
be very ugly
so king goes back we have rook to b4 and
now f4 so trying to you know do some
some work rugby three check king to f2
now rook a3 cutting the king off from
the
from the third rank now comes rook to d5
uh we have king to f7 and now rook to e5
uh we have rooked the king to f6 rookie
three offering rook trade of course we
cannot trade rooks because then the the
end game is winning for white so rook a4
now king f3 rook back to a1 and now rook
to b3 so now we're going to deliver some
checks rook to f1 check king to e3 rook
to e1 check king f2 uh espanko is still
losing so garish has to keep playing
with rook to e7 and king to g3 we have
rooked the a7 and now rook to b5 so of
course again we're going to try to get
our king into the into the game rook to
a3 check king to h4 and now rook back to
a7
and the rook the b6 check so we won the
g5 square for our king king to g7 now
comes uh rook to e6 of course if you try
king g5 uh alireza will just push you
back rook a5 check and now you know we
repeat the position or we play f5 and
this is again a very well known draw so
instead we have rook to e6 still uh
waiting to see what all it is that we'll
do king f7 we have rook to d6 and now
king back to g7 of course all it is i
can be only happy with the draw rook to
d3 and now king to f6 with king g3 rook
b7 king to f3 and now rook to e7 we have
rook d5 king to f7 rook d6 king g7 rook
to c6 and king to f7 so just you know
making some moves uh rook c4 uh king to
f6 rook to e4 and rook to a7 we have
rook to d4
if if you're checked you can go to e4 so
rook to e7 and now rook to d3 king f7
rook to a3 king to f6 and now king to g3
king f7 king h4 rook b7 and now king to
g5 uh and here yeah if you play rook to
b5 check here uh gerishuk
even creates a little crap if you
deliver a check here then king h6 is now
winning for white there's no way for you
to prevent uh uh you know losing here
you want to stop rookie seven so you
might play rook to b7 but now we're
going to play rook a4 and after black
wastes a move we're going to play g5 and
after he wastes another move we're of
course just going to play rook to a6 and
now we're going to play check pick up
the the pawn and just win the game so
there is the possibility of losing this
for for ali king to g7 of course is
played oh it is it doesn't uh go for
this rook a5 we have rook to c7 and now
rook to a6 we have rooked the c5 check
and now
we've tried everything we can f5 is
played g capture spawn captures and now
rook to c7 so of course uh uh gerichuk
will still test uh if alireza will will
draw this rook to g6 check king to f7
and now rook to h6 he has to try
everything
as this is a team event and russia is
losing so here we have king to g7 f6
check king the g8 and now king to g6 but
now uh it seems like the situation is uh
you know not all that great for black
there are many ways you can draw this
and the coolest one is the one that
alireza goes for and that's rook to g7
with check so now the rook cannot be
captured if you capture the rook then
it's just stalemate uh so he goes back
king to f5 we have rook to a7 uh and now
comes king back to g6 but now again rook
to g7 check
and here sasha captured on g7 and he was
in this position on move 86 that uh well
the players drew the game uh as alireza
has been stalemated
uh so uh no no 2800 for alireza uh just
yet uh but he does not lose any rating
because officially grishok is still
higher rated than alireza he's some
27.73 and there's 27.70
it's just that alireza won so much
rating in the live ratings which gets
updated every month but he just you know
got so much rating this month uh that it
still hasn't been updated it will be
updated on the first of december so uh
nothing really changes here no no change
in ratings alireza will get his uh
chance tomorrow again uh to
you know clear that 2800 mark but here
uh you know uh facing alexander grisham
with the black pieces well you've seen
what what did this means and and how
hard it was uh uh maybe maybe uh grishok
had a you know a couple of moments where
he could have played a little bit better
but that's a that's a big if you know
that's uh just an engine's
recommendation at a certain depth and
who knows of course segreshuk operates
at a much deeper depth uh so you know we
we will not adopt sasha at any point on
this channel
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh
there were you know
many
many
many uh traps in in the game but you
know no one uh no one fell for any of
them uh but here you can see just how
dangerous this can be uh this rook the
b8 move is very rare and of course
already i prepared something to surprise
grisha quit but uh obviously there's a
good reason it's very rare maybe it's
not very good and against a former 2800
player like grishok you know
it
that will not fly
so yeah uh once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
michael kennedy constantinos lampredis
rod hill tudor sharp and david kimura
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament cheering up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world the world
cheers championship is starting uh in a
few days ah see you soon